hey this is pressed Elle Walker and
you're watching mind your decisions when
a conical bottle rests on its flat base
the water in the bottle is 8 centimeters
from its vertex when the same conical
bottle is turned upside down the water
level is 2 centimeters from its base the
question is what is the height of the
bottle I was told this was a competition
problem for 8th graders which means
students who are aged roughly 12 to 13
years old can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
[Music]
so when I first got this problem I
thought it was actually a mistake how
can you solve it without knowing the
radius of the cone but amazingly it
works out
the idea is to solve for the volume of
water in both cones and then set them
equal to each other it all simplifies so
that you can solve for the height of the
cone so let's get started with the cone
on the Left we'll write H for the height
of the cone now let's set up some
triangles we have a large triangle where
it's a one leg is equal to the radius of
the circle at the bottom and we'll
denote that as R we have another
triangle where its base is the radius of
the upper cone and we'll write R sub 1
for that now let's determine the volume
of water this will be the difference in
volume of the large cone and the small
cone so this will be PI over 3 R squared
H minus PI over 3 R 1 squared times 8
now we can sim
by this formula a little bit by using
similar triangles the large triangle and
the small triangle are similar to each
other therefore the ratio of each leg to
each height is the same so we have our 1
over 8 is equal to R over H which means
our 1 is equal to 8 R over H we
substitute that in and then we simplify
to get an equation for the volume of
water it's PI over 3 times R squared
times the quantity H minus 512 over h
squared so let's keep that formula in
mind and then let's solve for the same
sort of formula for the other cone now
let's set up this diagram we have the
same height and the same radius of our
but then we want to solve for another
cone and we'll denote this radius as r2
we also need the height of this other
triangle since the entire height of the
cone is H and then it's 2 centimeters
from the top this dimension will be H
minus 2 we now want to solve for the
volume of water and that'll be the
volume of this small cone so we get the
formula PI over 3 R 2 squared times H
minus 2 again we'll use similar
triangles we have R 2 over H minus 2 is
equal to R over H this means R 2 is
equal to H minus 2 the quantity x are
all over H so we substitute that in and
then we simplify this to get the volume
of water in this cone is PI over 3 times
R squared times the quantity H minus 2
cubed all over H squared so we've
arrived at a pretty complicated formula
and it doesn't seem like we can solve
for the value of H however let's see
what we can do we've actually derived
two different equations for the volume
of water since all we've done is turn
the
koan upside down we know that the volume
of water in both cones has to be equal
so we set these two equations equal to
each other and now we have a miraculous
cancellation notice that PI over 3 times
R squared cancels out in both equations
the answer is independent of R and the
length of the radius of the large cone
cancels out so we now want to solve for
the value of H after we multiply both
sides by H squared we get the equation h
cubed minus 512 is equal to the quantity
H minus 2 cubed will expand out H minus
2 cubed to the following we have H cubed
minus 6 H squared plus 12 H minus 8 we
then simplify both formulas by
cancelling H cubed and then we get a
quadratic formula 6 H squared minus 12 H
minus 504 is equal to 0 we divide by 6
to get a squared minus 2 H minus 84 is
equal to 0 now we can use the quadratic
formula and we're looking for a positive
solution because the height of the cone
has to be positive so we get that H is
equal to 1 plus the square root of 85
and this is approximately equal to 10
point 2 centimeters and amazingly we
figured out the height of the cone did
you figure it out thanks for watching
this video these math videos which can
be watched for free on youtube inspire
and build confidence where people around
the world and they already have over a
hundred million views let's share the
beauty of mathematics with your help we
can map the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all the mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle or
topic presh and mind your decisions calm
and if you so choose you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support